Problems with access to housing
At the same time,
1,800,000 apartments are empty.
why or
Poles do not want to make money on rented apartments
They want to but are afraid
The rules are designed so
If someone does not pay you for the rented apartment
There's nothing you can do to him.
first for 01: 03 months
Nothing you can do at all
If he still doesn't pay you
You can send him a letter asking for payment.
within a month
If he does not pay
Only then can you terminate the contract.
with one month s notice
together it gives 5 months
When someone doesn't pay you
Once the contract expires
There's nothing you can do about it.
You can only go to court.
who is a few years old
to consider your application and give judgment
You already have a court order,
there's nothing you can do about it.
you pass it to the bailiff
that again Nothing can do about it
because it has to wait
until the municipality grants this man a substitute home
which can take several years
the effect is such
that for a few years someone destroys your apartment
does not pay you for the apartment and makes debts co-operatives
what can be done about it
We need to change these rules so
The law protects the honest
Not wanting to live at someone else s expense.